what you're about to watch is a clip
from my brand lytics training where i
get together with entrepreneurs thought
leaders who want to build their brand
using youtube and making data driven
decisions to blow up their brand this
year enjoy
what's up brand linux how are we doing
welcome i'm excited for today's topic
this is a good one this is why i always
love making the topics around what you
guys want to talk about because i don't
know that i would have
come up with this as a topic but you
guys picked it so i'm excited to go
today's topic how do you move people
from watching your video to some kind of
offer i love it and listen it's super
important because it's not just about
getting subscribers and views most of
you i hope want to build a business
right we're not just trying to be
influencers we're trying to actually
build a business try to make money doing
this uh just so we can hire team and
reach more people and continue to expand
our reach i've got 30 something people
my team
uh that doesn't happen if i'm not you
know making money from the videos it's
great to have however many millions of
subscribers and views and all that but
we have to be able to turn it into
something
um and with with offers you can also go
deeper with people okay show the process
this is not so much of a hardcore
sales
strategy
more of taking me deep into what you're
naturally already great at
so that it makes me curious
that i want to reach out to you that i
want to check out your your profile that
i want to find your website that i want
to do some kind of work with you so
two weeks ago
uh when we had paul on
he had shared on one of his channels i
forget how many subscribers this channel
has paul maybe you can remind us in the
chat i think it was in the in the low
hundreds of subscribers
he was posting these short videos and
you know three minute videos here and it
had 34 views and he does hypnosis and
then he posted a full video of his stage
work of him doing a full show it was an
hour and a half
and
this was not with any paid this is all
organic got 4 000 views for channel with
a couple hundred subscribers that's
fantastic and we use that in the context
of
longer videos work it's really hard to
get a three minute video to rank so
longer videos work i'd love to see at
least the 10 minute mark
but if you can go an hour and a half
that's fantastic we're getting some of
our best results with three hour videos
eight hour videos though mashing up
pieces together could be really good um
and i'd love to see
just trying to go longer on the content
maybe you can get that to six seven
eight you'll start to see better results
with where youtube's at right now
that was what we talked about a couple
weeks ago though but for this it's
showing the process so if paul's got a
great hypnosis show
if he keeps putting out the show even if
he never says
hire me even if he never says buy my
book or buy my course or bring me to
your event or i do corporate gigs even
if he never says that just showing the
process
will get people who want to work with
him
i got my first speaking gig
uh that's not true not my first weekend
but one of my first speaking gigs my
first like big speaking gig i guess the
first where i was the keynote speaker i
was in kuala lumpur
and i got flown in
because the guy had seen my youtube
videos
and i never
had anywhere in my videos hey hire me if
you need someone to speak hire me hire
me hire me
because i was showing me speaking
people reached out and wanted to hire me
to come and speak i still get a lot of
my speaking gigs now mostly virtual i
know all virtual right now
but i still get them all because people
see me speak on my youtube videos even
though
there's nowhere actually in any of my
sequences or funnels or anything that
talks about me being a speaker
or or hiring me
they see it and they want more so paul
if paul kept putting on these hypnosis
shows
that's what he does
again i know right now might be a little
difficult during covert but if he's
putting on those shows
he will get corporations and
organizations reaching out to say hey
how can we work with you i love that
show you did can you make that happen
for us
make sense paul says yeah that channel
had was a little more
a little over 100 right so channel this
again shows the process of what you're
great at this required less work to do
than a lot of his
full-on videos where he's direct the
camera because it's just
taping the show and and there was no
editing on this and no fancy
music or anything it was just the actual
show
and it did really well for him so um
congrats what's he saying since i put
that full stage hypnosis video i'm up
over 1 000 on views view time and new
subscribers in the last 28 days
i love it dude that's great and it was
just an experiment so congrats and again
golden long showing your process makes a
huge difference
uh next
let's get to you guys so ashley uh i
don't know if ash is here in the house
but actually is from the tapping
solution and
they
i know i know the founders uh
nick
ortner
started this company with his family and
they help you get rid of your stress
through tapping and if you go to their
facebook page you go to their website
you go to their their content you'll see
all of these amazing people doing
tapping so you see dr oz doing tapping
you'll see them teaching wayne dyer how
to do tapping and
i don't know all the ins and outs but
you're tapping all the different you
know you got you tapping here you're
tapping here and you're tapping on your
wrists and
showing people how to tap jennifer says
she loves tapping
uh so it's great and they have all these
case studies and testimonials and videos
but here's what's interesting when you
go to their facebook page look at the
top the biggest call to action right
here is use the app
and this is where you have to understand
what is the business
goal that you're trying to accomplish
what do we want to drive people what do
we want people to know about us beyond
just watching our videos in education
what ultimately are we trying to sell
are we trying to sell a coaching program
are you trying to sell
stage work shows are you trying to sell
an app a book mentorship like what are
you actually trying to sell and then
showing me the process of doing it so if
i look at this page i think
and i know a little bit about the
company anyway but even if i didn't i'd
say okay they want to promote their app
so what should the videos be on their
channel
somebody using the app
instead of nick just guiding people
through how to do this
it should be nick
doing
loading the app and saying okay today
we're gonna do our
our uh tapping on anxiety or we're gonna
do our tapping on
uh
whatever it is you're gonna tap away
there's like so many versions of tapping
that they have inside their app having
somebody actually load the app and then
do
one of the free tapping sessions as a
video without even having to say that
this is a free app or there's a 90-day
trial or you know whatever offer you've
got just the fact that you're using it
makes me curious to say oh my gosh how
do i how do i get a part of it
ashley says this is for ashley she's
writing so you think you should like
listen to the meditation that's in the
app versus walking people through the
meditation that's interesting yes
if
your goal is to get people to use the
app
right so if your goal is i want people
to sign up for our app which as i
believe that's the goal yeah okay so she
confirmed that that's the goal then i
want to see nick or whoever come on
camera load the app
and say okay today we're gonna do a
meditation from our tapping solution app
this is great for without improving the
app this is great for whatever like
again benefits of tapping benefits
meditation
okay let's press play and let's dive in
again you're showing me the process what
do you want to sell and then show me the
process of you actually using the thing
so it's not this disjointed thing
afterwards so not just somebody
meditating one of the other founders
meditating and then saying by the way
we've got this free app that can help
you show me actually using the process
right
uh
i pulled out jennifer so uh jennifer had
this great post on instagram
uh shout out to jennifer i see her here
live too
and she wrote so here at the top when my
tot throws a tantrum i just start
breathing to calm myself the flip down i
love it then i think what was the thing
from that one parenting podcaster book i
read on how to deal with this and then i
highlighted this part
on days like these i'm definitely
wearing a piece of uh chalcedony
if i pronounce that close enough all
right
uh which has calming properties and
helps me reduce anger and doubt okay
what would be great as content so this
is something everybody can relate to
right every parent can definitely relate
to this i think about you know my son or
my nieces or nephews uh they're a little
beyond that stage now you know they're
like uh 10 years old but when they were
younger just constantly freaking out and
feeling like you're making mistakes
everywhere and you're the you know edge
of your patient zone
i would love to see this as a video
so instead of just showing
you know your arm and then i can see the
the you know the it's not a b the
jewelry here and here
show me you going through it my
son is freaking out and it's driving me
crazy and so here's what i do when this
happens
you see this
stone here's here's what it does
here's how it has healing properties and
so
and then whatever you do whether you sit
down and you look at it or you just put
it on you meditate with it
so show what picture it's a video show a
video of you freaking out
with you with like your hair all over
the place and
you stressing out like right here this
basically i want to see it happening
instead of you just showing this perfect
picture
i want to see you being the mom with a
talk who's freaking out and you're
trying to calm yourself
down and
and then what do you do how do you
actually get calm well the jewelry helps
you get calm and there's a process that
you go through
that i would love to see that as a video
maybe maybe you're tapping as well maybe
it's a combination of the of the jewelry
and the tapping
but whatever you do to make that
actually work
um
as a video you don't even then have to
sell or promote the jewelry you're doing
it through the process of showing me how
you
are getting out of this struggle that
you're dealing with with your tot
all right so it's it's much more
effective than just having this is great
copy the picture is great
but i don't see you
freaking out or stressed out or needing
the calm to flip down which would be
great to see even if you do an instagram
copy this could be a good carousel
picture of you like
but real like this was me today not some
fake like you on a green screen pulling
your hair but this is actually me today
and here's what happened and then the
next one over is this that's a good
instagram strategy but for youtube
how many how many moms uh because i know
that's your that's your tribe how many
moms are struggling with with their kids
and stressing out and freaking out and
you know so showing me that you are one
of them and here's how to get through it
and here's how you get through it and
this is what you do um some people will
think well that's ridiculous like
jewelry can't help me do that and other
people will be like that's amazing
what's the name of that thing chalcedony
how do i get one
how do i where's your website
so you're just showing me the process of
you doing that thing
it's hard to film during a tantrum
very smart thanks yeah even even think
about it afterwards like you
you you're not gonna and you probably
don't want to film your child freaking
out behind you right just for privacy
and everything else but
after it's happened you're still
stressed out you finally put them down
or or somebody's taking over or they're
having a snack or they're napping or
whatever and you're still but you're
still feeling the emotions of
feeling
overwhelmed and like a failure and not
knowing what to do and needing a break
and having too much anxiety and so
that's when you make the video
this is so valuable appreciate this
insight um awesome hey that's what we're
here for brand lyrics let's go
if you want to see this full video as
well as train live with me twice a month
to blow up your brand join the brand
linux training program there's a link to
join right there next to me continue to
believe i'll see you there